well hello reject nation it's Greg Alba
here with I'll let hobb a crazy catch
her twitch stream you can catch her on
YouTube she's a gamer gamer nerd gamer
gamer nerd female keyword nerd
she just got engaged to the man I
introduced her to so cuz of this guy
well good to me i forced him to date and
now they're engaged our first
interaction ever was on the real rejects
anyway she took a trip to see his
parents and then she stopped by an
antique shop and picked me up this
little Batman comic right here number
one number one vintage bad boy Thank You
Alyssa be crazy nuts in a while since
I've unboxed the 1up box
can you be my presenter here is this a
Batman now yeah that I need a starter
gave me you can use it to cut open that
a needle I cut away for myself otherwise
I feel like bad things will happen I
can't see what's in the box so what do
you need to do is get out the pamphlet
thing so we know what a month and theme
it is 1up box if you're watching you
should just put that on the front it's
on the top is this on the top so that
way we know even when we do an unboxing
video you still let me know I'm ready
you ready yeah
today's theme is a despair it's
Halloween it was so dark
alright I'm ready I could go over some
Halloween goodies keep this shirt last I
don't know why since know you've done
this shirt early before a member I
remember wow sorry with that pop bigger
huh oh
hey I got a Darryl one of this I think I
got a Darryl one from the 1up box
actually this is so neat is awesome
that's not Rick
that's Eugene
I think that's Eugene now that's Rick
that is totally well thanks to on that
box that's all I needed
yeah yeah the tiny okay this is mighty
minis whoo I only see a cave I think you
know I I think it's a gold Superman
oh it's they got all these pieces you
got to put together yourself bull oh
it's a gold Superman that's cool
I put the left arm on the right
ambidextrous no he can still get what
suppose ambidextrous oh I bet he
couldn't perform certain activities in
the bedroom
oh I mean look at this is a gold
Superman oh that's really neat you know
if I wanted a Superman I'd have wanted
to be gold a lock my wallet wallak coz
of the yellow dollar bill signs that
come up on YouTube videos these days as
an inside joke for anyone who has a
youtube channel oh god is this a is this
a sticker it is a nightmare before
christmas sticker look I gotta tell you
guys I have a list of movies on my phone
that I have not seen it's gone the list
is called movies that I get crap for not
having seen you've never seen not too
mad before Christmas is on there like
gasps a happy Halloween to you Alyssa
that's all yeah oh my god you can do so
much for that you put it on your trash
what's this halloween tattoos
[Laughter]
yes we're putting one on right now I
really do love temporary tattoos you're
the best
I used to go on Amazon and actually just
order temporary tattoos of what Batman
and Batman villain all right boy I have
a question for you
yes so this would be crazy brides man I
don't know what else to call it but it's
a bride's man rides man have you
introduced us then has no room
and it was so funny get-together you've
seen the start of it you saw that weird
ass day where I got drunk on my birthday
was like I think I like him and you guys
were like no [ __ ] you told us that you
liked him you're like guys I have
something to tell you I think I like Dan
and we were just waiting for you to be
like yeah that's it like oh yeah we
already knew a pin it's a pumpkin Fox is
that what it is
okay that's exciting I'm so glad I have
that pity shirt this shirt I do inform
them I lost weight sure babe it just
won't bring up my arms
won't show your tongue my tone arms the
only part of my body that's kind of
toned all right here we go
don't look at me I'm just kidding I mean
I can't divert my eyes I want you to I
was just watching mr. plinkus review of
Ghostbusters the remake where he was
bashing the movie for one hour did you
get to see it yeah most people don't
like it I personally thought it was
funny but hey it still fits okay well
and also after a washable string boy
katha sighs yeah what if it glows in the
dark do you think so Hey well that's
just us find out later kids whoa guys
okay yourself what up box today there's
a link in the description box you could
be rockin the same shirt I'm wearing
right now wouldn't you feel special look
at that oh dude I love these guys I love
I love adding to my toy collection well
you guys can subscribe to the real
rejects go get yourself a 1up box and if
you get one why don't you Instagram me
or tweet me so I